how's come raise my spoon today we're
gonna play a game with the oculus it's
called mental torment doesn't that sound
like a [ __ ] holiday can't wait to
play this hello
let's go in ahh what was that oh god
[ __ ] I forget how scary the oculus is a
horror experience well I don't know what
else he would expect with a game with
that title but I'm not [ __ ] me really
you have to scare me with a [ __ ] font
making fun of me on YouTube is that what
you want
it's act watching otherwise it's just
damn it
alright we're we're I think we're fine
oh oh Jesus Christ we're so [ __ ] dead
Isis follow this can I go down there oh
great ah it's that is that chocolate
pudding yeah yeah yeah god I love
chocolate pudding
I [ __ ] how did they know my birthday
was last week guys you're late okay
let's disgusting leave nice actually
quite like it think I have a weird boner
- oh Jesus what do you like what do you
want from me huh oh it's my reflection
are you trying to ready kill me again
huh what'd I say
who'd do that
hello don't think I'm scared cuz I'm not
scared I'm only scared when I scream and
I never scream what was that
I I played enough horror games to know
what you're gonna do next
so don't think I don't I'm not scared
alright just gonna go this way now
instead good tricked out Oh a demon's
signature that means this place is
correct
blessed by Satan damn it
Oh God
hello hello hey did something wrong what
happened
why do is that I'm alive a tsunami like
Eliza say senorita I feel the Congo I
hear some Nazi activity going on in the
hallways damn it let me in please was
that I think I just I I don't what was
that she she was she with what but just
I'm not sure if I should like or dislike
that it's fine don't worry bro I know
what I'm doing the ambience now that's
just their death calling me that's not a
big deal no reason to Jesus [ __ ] ass
stop it stop it
dammit what's going on stop it
glasses no bad bad what's going on you
kid oh hello is anyone in here and now I
can move stuff and we're [ __ ] fine
look at this I'm not scaring you
haha as easy I figured that out all by
myself
oh [ __ ] you get out get out get out
can't tell me what you do piece of [ __ ]
stupid ass what's that sound hello you
really have to puke on all the walls
damn it okay
sure oh I'll I'll go inside I guess oh
god no no no no no no I don't want to
play I am busy
my mom says I can't go out I don't want
to do anything
don't touch my nipples whatever you do
okay what's going on I'm just gonna go
oh that was close he almost took touch
my nipples that was a close one
I was weird what goes on here going this
time my baby gonna hold her tight and
gonna grab [ __ ] where did you come from
what'd I tell you about my neck don't
touch when the bus stupid lamp piece of
[ __ ] oh god [ __ ] my ass senpai senpai oh
god I gotta follow him Sacrament senpai
suck my ass
senpai where you going step by senpai
hello wait for me senpai he left his
order damn it's a pie every time when
will they notice me [ __ ] senpai [ __ ]
keep following the bun battle I mean the
blood pudding that's what it is
it's nothing else it's a video game
games can't hurt me
games can't hurt me long-ass corridor
goddamnit
Oh God the naked [ __ ] again what is she
what is this I don't I don't care if you
have blood pudding on you that's that
just nothing for me nothing alright
alright well that was fun let's do that
again call me call me babe
Kagami maybe hey I just got molested and
that was crazy
here's my number don't call me please oh
god here we go
a lot of stairs huh are we going exact
to them blood pudding lovely ready for
this that's cool dammit I can't be stuck
in the blood pudding bath maybe I need
to swim maybe
what's right is it's a whale it's a
German whale they're quite rare at this
part of the land damn German Deutschland
whale ah [ __ ] me well [ __ ] get a laugh
[ __ ] think I'm scary cuz you're a
German whale
yeah bigger problem [ __ ] me
damn Tracy sign of Aflac me when I just
say okay
[ __ ] I was I was sad that was crazy but
here's my number
the comic shut up damn it what is all
these noises
stop listen you're about to be missing
I'm I'm I go pissing on your face or
Kelly style [ __ ]
oh this place looks fabulous I shall go
here take me home country roads Tudor
place get the [ __ ] off me car bed no I'm
sorry
what no way you're so mean why